Chứ thông tin về việc cảnh sát áo phát hiện thuốc dịch truật trong thức an giảm hiếp.
Cũng an toàn thực phẩm Bộ I.T.
yêu cầu các địa phương giả phát sản phẩm này trên toàn quốc.
Sản phẩm năm trong diện cảnh báo hình là loại hú một chăm chỉ mở gram viết ca. Quay tầy.
Cơ quan trích năng là thời hạn trước ngày 20 hình thử,
đơn vị nhập khâu phải báo gáo toàn bộ số lượng hàng đánh nhập.
Bán ra và tôn khô để có biện pháp sự lý trị đề.
Đồng thời, khuyến cáu phụ hình cần chú đồng kiểm tra tu đoán của con và tuệt lối vứt bỏ các lo hàng năm trong dành xách cảnh báo,
nhằm bảo vệ an toàn xức khỏe cho chẻ.
Đồng thời này được đưa ra trong buổi cạnh sản phẩm an giảm hiếp.
Bí tu hồi tại một nhiên năm trong cửa hàng của chuyến sư thi spa tại áo,
sau kết quả sét nhẹ mẫu thử từ hú an giảm viết ca. Rốt và khoái tầy.
Loại một chăm chính mời gram kết quả dân tính với thuốc dịch truật.